-In honor of Veterans Day,
we partnered
with our friends at T-Mobile
and filled our entire audience
with veterans
and their families.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And here at "The Tonight Show,"
we like to play a lot of games,
and tonight, I want to play
a game with you guys.
It's time for
the "Whisper Challenge."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whisper Challenge.
-Now, before we start,
I need someone to play with.
So, everyone, look at
your seat number right there,
and if I call your number,
I want you to stand up
and come on down here.
You ready for this?
Drumroll, please.
Here we go.
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants me
to pick their number?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Number 418.
4-1-8.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
4-1-8.
Is there no one here?
Is there no one here at 4-1-8?
Shall I...
choose another one?
Come on down, hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
Come on!
♪♪
Here, I have a --
You don't look happy,
that you want to play.
What's the problem?
Yes.
Yes, I'm serious right now.
Absolutely.
I'm gonna put this microphone
on you right here.
-This is serious?
-This is for reals.
-Is this on TV?
-This is on TV.
Yes, it's on TV.
[ Laughter ]
What?
Here, you put this
in your pocket.
[ Laughing ]
You put that in your pocket
if you want.
What?
[ Laughing ]
This reaction --
I've never seen anyone
react like this in my lifetime.
What is your name,
first of all?
-India.
-India Horn.
Well, welcome, India.
Are you a veteran?
-I am. Well, I'm active duty,
but I'm a vet, as well.
-Okay, very good.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you very much.
Anyone else in your family
in the military?
-My husband is, as well.
-Oh, is he here
with you tonight?
-Oh, no,
he's deployed right now.
-Well, if he's watching...
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you're watching,
she's doing great so far.
[ Laughter ]
All right, we're gonna play
the "Whisper Challenge."
Please have a seat,
and I'll explain it to you.
All right,
now here's how it works.
One person will put on
these pair of headphones
right here, okay?
And we're gonna play loud music.
Okay?
Then the other person
will pick up a card
and read the phrase
written on the card,
and the person
wearing the headphones
tries to guess
what they're saying.
-Okay, say that one more time.
[ Laughter ]
I'm trying to focus.
This is a lot.
-We could pick another ping-pong
ball if it makes it easier.
One of us is gonna put on
these headphones, okay?
You'll go first.
It's loud music on here.
And then the other person
will pick up this card
and read what's on the card.
And you have to guess just by
reading my lips what I'm saying.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Whew!
Okay.
We're already --
We're into the first hour
of the "Today Show" already.
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
This is, uh...
All right, this is left.
-You got this!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right,
I'm gonna play loud music.
And let me know
if you can hear it?
All right, can you hear me?
[ Laughter ]
That means no.
Okay, good.
Here we go.
Let's play the game.
This is gonna be fun.
[ Laughter ]
All right, here we go.
I'm a little teapot.
[ Laughter ]
-One more time.
-I'm a little teapot.
[ Laughter ]
-One more time.
-I'm.
-Up.
-A little.
-Lair?
-Teapot.
-Pop.
[ Laughter ]
I -- I got nothing.
-I'm a little teapot.
-Oh, I'm a teapot!
-Yeah, yeah, that's good.
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's hard, right?
-Yeah.
-It's hard.
All right, here we go.
I'm gonna put these on,
and then, you read me that one.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, okay.
Lady Gaga.
-Letta kaka.
[ Laughter ]
-Lady Gaga.
Lady.
-Daddy?
-Lady.
Lady.
-Steak.
[ Laughter ]
-Lady.
-Fakey.
-No.
-Lay --
-Lie. Lay.
-Lady.
-Lay cakey.
[ Laughter ]
Lay.
-La-dy.
-Lady!
Lady.
Lady Gaga!
-Yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whew!
No, that was good.
It was good.
It was you.
Lady Gaga, that's my girl.
Okay, here we go.
All right.
[ Laughter ]
Your husband is behind you.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-What?
-Your husband is behind you.
Your.
-Huh?
-Your.
-Tour?
-Tour.
-Your.
-Your husband is behind you.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪
Oh, my God!
Look at you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You can --
You can take these off.
Take these off.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my goodness.
Come on.
-I was gonna get you one day.
-Did you have any idea at all?
She almost didn't want
to come down from the seats.
Did you see it backstage?
-Oh, yeah, I saw.
-It was unbelievable.
India...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Relax.
-Well, we have another --
We have another
surprise for you.
-There's more?
-Yes.
We partnered with T-Mobile
to not only honor veterans
but also support them
in the community.
And, India, T-Mobile
heard that you were trying
to raise money
to redo the family room
in the pediatric
intensive care unit
at the Walter Reed
National Military Medical Center
in Maryland.
T-Mobile is going
to take care of that.
They're going to cover
all the costs
of redoing the family room.
Absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
They're gonna make sure
it's perfect.
They're gonna make sure it's
perfect.
And, Cory,
there's a few more people here
that want to see you.
Your kids, Cory.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi! Hi!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Daddy! Daddy!
Daddy!
-Oh, my God.
-Daddy!
-We'll be right back
with more of "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
Come on back!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-Were you really surprised?
[ Cheers and applause ]